Ashcombe breasts - babe ha today we're
playing one of mine all-time favorite
games rollercoaster tycoon
isn't it beautiful look at it oh man
that nostalgic sound I have no idea
whatsoever if this will be even mildly
entertaining to watch but I thought it
would be fun to revisit my old favorite
game like I say so we'll start with
forest frontiers this is the most basic
theme park out of all time so this is
what we got to work with what should we
name our theme park that's the most
essential step see if I remember how to
you changed there you go um but Park yes
I am 12 the park isn't open yet we can
start building stuff and then open it
but I'm a little [ __ ] and I'll gonna
open it right away because I can cash in
on the entrance fee which is here we
should set it to two dollars two dollars
to see a couple of park bench I think
that's a fair deal Oh
some [ __ ] just paid it by the
entrance we should feel like these
shitty rides that that just you can cash
in like a [ __ ] on like this this
slide thing I don't know why damn it
it's been so long as I play this I don't
even remember the thing with this game
that I think the reason why it's my
favorite game is because uh one of my
forget I'm sorry it it doesn't matter
that the game is really really old it's
it's like it hasn't aged a bit
our first ride is now open
how much are we charging for it free the
[ __ ] you think this is at least 40
pounds
quit Oh a lot of guests coming in here
oh whoa whoa that slide must really must
really have done the trick didn't a
people oh my god they're just barging it
they want to go on my slide ask slide a
slide a slider that's pretty clever holy
[ __ ] my first guess it's going on the a
slider yes this one is really exciting
you know what you should build this one
booth genius you know what we can delete
all these [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
squirrels and put that there
[ __ ] genius where's my Nobel award
actually you know what that's pretty
dumb goddamn it I deleted all the
squirrels for no reason at all don't
worry about it
I know it's bothering you too that I
don't really know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing it's gonna be okay
there we go look at it look at all these
idiots going in the exit so dumb all
right cool you can add a test text here
don't go here you [ __ ] does it say
that does it say that please let it say
that don't go there
you [ __ ] arts hahahaha set it in the
exit it'll say hope you enjoyed my ass
goddamn it is raining you know what you
do when it rains you capitalize on that
[ __ ] you can get an information Chomsky
god damn baby we don't have it okay that
means we have to research then there's
so many aspects to this game listen crew
of increase increase our funding so
maybe we'll discover it but for now it's
raining that's okay
we could have had like sell super
expensive umbrellas and [ __ ] let's build
one more attraction before we build the
roller coaster how about that your Park
receive their award for being the most
disappointing all right
[ __ ] you okay alright stay on track we
will we can recover for this this is not
the end there you go
so right there by the back open that
[ __ ] uh spin that ass there you go spin
that ass open open for business why is
it free [ __ ] you I need money my god
what do you think it is a [ __ ]
charity Viking asses free tier with the
[ __ ] all these freeloaders also another
really funny thing you can do is you can
set the line for free and then once all
these people enter you can just up the
price like a [ __ ] oh man I love
this game I think you can tell all right
a research team just made it so we can
build a ferris wheel
amazing if the same was here right now
he'd say the same thing my why is
everyone going on the [ __ ] thing
alright we need we obviously need
something more exciting all right this
one is going to blow their goddamn minds
now you can select pretty pre-built ones
but to me
building the roller coasters it's like
one of the most fun things of the game
you want to have good spaceman it's
really annoying you can [ __ ] up I think
I already [ __ ] that there we go long
entry because we need like a lot of
[ __ ] people to get it right so it
goes up now yeah it's gonna go more okay
and then it's just gonna go straight
[ __ ] down genius alright this is a
bad idea okay so it's gonna go down like
this yes then it's actually gonna go up
a little bit
look at that and now that seems stupid
this is pretty amazing I think this is
could potentially be the greatest roller
coaster of all time look at this it goes
over itself bet you haven't seen that
[ __ ] man I should really just quit
YouTube and become like a rollercoaster
person I think that's the official title
all right we're gonna make it it's good
to use the space like around the roller
coaster I can tell how little shits you
give but I'm gonna tell you all about it
anyway
oh [ __ ] I ran out of money
god dammit no problem I bet you're
thinking oh god how we will finish his
amazing roller coaster had we build
together pairs I know it's okay
we can let borrow money we're all
technically already in debt that's okay
we'll make the money back oh look at
this perfect now here's the hardest part
to connect the [ __ ] if you know
what I mean there it is
Bam Bam rollercoaster finito
rollercoaster one we're not even gonna
test run it Mitch is open and it's
expensive like [ __ ] to two bucks [ __ ]
yes I I spend so much money on this why
aren't you going [ __ ]
look at this it's amazing
why snow I going what the [ __ ]
I spread so much money
you're all [ __ ] I hate you my god
you know what fine fine fine all right
we'll build the caterpillar cat crazy
caterpillar this one no wait there's I
remember this crazy caterpillar is like
the big moneymaker you can this place is
[ __ ] down and you'll be rich look at
this [ __ ] crazy-ass pillar that we
should call it I think yes a Spiller ask
puller okay why not
I won't see right why don't they go in
this is crazy as [ __ ]
caterpillar all right all right plan
[ __ ] I don't even know all right
we're gonna do shuttler this is amazing
I love this this is a moneymaker
it's a [ __ ] loop look at that [ __ ]
who wouldn't want to go that [ __ ] oh my
god I got an amazing idea
it's gonna be so cool holy [ __ ] just
wait you don't know what I'm doing right
now but like you wish you knew I mean I
force you boys look at this can you can
you can you guess can you guess what I'm
gonna do with this [ __ ] bet you can oh
[ __ ] it [ __ ] goes through the loop
what that [ __ ] out of this think of the
[ __ ] like that that's so [ __ ] cool
probably really dangerous if you have
like a really scary Park you need like
at least 40 people just wiping all the
puke oh okay okay they would see they
really like this one I knew that because
I knew that you know what since these
are so cheap and people love going on
them let's do another one
make a double shuffle Luke for science
oh [ __ ] look at that [ __ ] man I am a
crazy [ __ ] ha ha ha you know
what we're gonna do
tell me tell me if you know no one's
gonna be able to go through this it goes
through it it goes through the [ __ ]
thing okay
alright we can't feel higher than that
how cool is that you know what let's
make it a Sweden color that one's yellow
whenever I play this we're Marcia she
put so much attention to put in colors
and it's super annoying just want to
point that out
holy [ __ ] oh god oh god don't crash
don't crash don't crash yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome you know what that's
free that's that one's on the house bit
why are you mowing the lawn that [ __ ] no
one gives a [ __ ] about the mall you
idiot you didn't pick up uke there's
puke right there no one is going on my
roller coaster - they're all too scared
all right you know what this was a bad
idea okay you know what I think we're
gonna have to end the first episode of
what's called
but Park here if you want me to keep
playing this I'll be happy to and other
than that I just had fun to revisit one
of my favourite old games and I hope
as well other than that think about
watching I'll see you in the next one as
always stay awesome and out of wrong
yeah
that's why I killed the generator
because I really wanted food I thought
that would be like chicken nuggets in
there or some chips look how [ __ ]
huge I am don't you think I need some
chicken [ __ ] nuggets